اذا المواجهات بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع طرحت العديد من الاسئله الملحه
بشان عديد قوات الطرفين ومواقع انتشارهما
قبل بدء الحرب وصولا الى اليوم الجيش
السوداني يقدر عدد منتسبي الجيش السوداني
بنحو 150 الف عنصر وتتمركز قواته في قواعد
معروفه منذ عده عقود في مختلف انحاء
البلاد قوات الدعم السريع تقدر عددها بنحو
100 الف عنصر من الضباط المنتدبين من
الجيش والجنود وتمتلك عده مقر بعضها يعود
للجيش السوداني تنتشر في معظم الولايات
البلاد لكن انتشارها الاكبر هو في ولايه
دارفور الخمس الى جانب ولايه جنوب وشمال
وغرب كردفان توجد قوات الدعم السريع بشكل
كبير في ولايه البحر الاحمر ولها مواقع
ايضا بالقرب من منطقه حلايب
سبق وان استولت وبموافقه الجيش على مقات
في الخرطوم على مقار في الخرطوم منها جهاز
الامن الوطني وجهاز المخابرات السابق
وهيئه العمليات ومبنى لحزب المؤتمر الوطني
المنحل